hey guys this is andrew from
trainsenses.com i'm a professional
trainer for the past six years in hong
kong and i've been working for several
big investment banks like hsbc or
commerce bank and i've just started to
make some youtube videos
because i want to pass the knowledge
guys i want to share with you all my
experience of six years of pro trading
and i want to show you the different
techniques that i use what is working
for me what is not
so if you want to understand how we
actually work
as pro traders you are in the right
place so today i want to talk about
uh i want to finish the list of the
penny stocks i was talking about
that i find on reddit that i find on
twitter on wall street bets i hang out
on this forums
and i pick up some stocks and i just
analyze
it for you guys and i try to show you
what i would do
uh in any situation so let's get into it
[Music]
so blnk same thing guys so i
get i got my list on this forums and i
did a short list so you know
uh i have like you know so many uh you
know
potential stocks i could show you but
i'm just
picking uh those that to me uh are
interesting to talk about you see so you
have like for example clvs dds google
this one i talked about it uh bbby i
talked about it so basically all these
guys they mostly talk about the same
stuff you can see and those are hot
stocks guys when you look at them most
of them
uh got some crazy performances in the
past
uh month so all right let's go back to
what i was talking about so bl
nk first thing so i'm checking the
market cap i'm checking the short
interest all right small market cap big
shoot interest
makes it a target for those guys so this
makes it very interesting for me to look
at so two billion
uh so it's quite small all right so it's
close to you know clbs
who was a beautiful client my two
favorite targets are pgen and
dds invite you guys to uh check this
video i did
uh on those two uh blnk 25 percent of
shirt interest two billion market cap
let's have a look at it so same thing we
have
like here a trend line all right so one
two three three reactions
then we break it we don't retest it i
don't really like it so it makes my
trendline weaker
but we still have it and then look what
we have here some consolidation
why because guys it was you know the
maximum level that we had
here in this period right so you can put
it maybe here
you know it's not very clean i'm not
sure we are above we are
below i would put it here because this
is what i see here
this is you know the minimum it works as
well in this area all right so if it
works in this area means it was support
here
so it's resistance here and right now
for me guys if you bought it here
and you know you bought this breakout
and you made 350 guys it's time to take
profit
so for me this is uh
not a stock i would buy it's a stock i
would actually
sell uh and then if you want to buy it i
would be buyer of this
at around the breakout level always a
nice level to buy
so around 12 uh okay i'm gonna buy
around 12 on the seller at 55 then if
you go higher guys if something like
this happens
attack and then you know we do some
stuff here
maybe i would be a buyer all right if we
break it and then we test
i would be a buyer around this area for
sure but for now this is not what is
happening all right guys
so so i'm not the buyer of this one
next one s i g three billion market
capitalization i didn't find the short
interest guys i don't know
why it's not available but let's look at
the technicals
the technicals are beautiful we have so
earnings uh earnings are really bad
all right but you know some of them had
really bad earnings and they went
very high so it's not that much of a
problem
but for me it's not good news i don't
like to see earnings going lower it's
not about being negative all right
actually those ones are positive but
it's just they're going lower you know
so it's not good
the price action is going higher though
so maybe we're gonna have some good
surprise
on the earnings next year and here we
have this uh downloads floating
trendline
that has been broken and retested guys
all right broken retested we go higher
i like this kind of situation and we are
actually quite close to this
you can even you know do something like
this
and if we have the double signals
if in like the 19th of march we are
trading at 34 guys it's a massive
buy all right it's a massive mine as we
say in
uh trading and targets guys there would
be
around so same thing i try you know just
look quickly
i haven't done this before the
consolidation level so
here is it a good one this one is good
because you can see here it was
resistance
here it will support support ram
resistance
so the next resistance level is here
guys all right
and you have if you buy it here you have
100
uh upside move that you can make and
once again guys
make trade with the tight stop loss all
right maximum on the staff 15
so you have one to six uh risk reward
ratio which is very good
and once again as i said in my previous
videos guys don't put
uh all your money in one of the stuff
you know just
find the ones where you have the best
signals i invite you guys to check on my
youtube channel i have done some
analysis on all of them
and i see some nice signals on those
ones
so those three pg en dds
sig clvs is beautiful too but i think
it's a bit too late
google is like more taking profits blm
kept taking profits as well
football bbb why are nice as well
all this list guys you can have some
nice stuff happening you just need to
follow it
and to use the techniques i'm showing
you guys here so
i hope this helped you to understand how
pro traders are working how i work
i'm going to keep updating you guys with
all the stuff so please click on the
like button and subscribe button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys